welcome to exploring computing
today's video is hexadecimal
so we've seen inside the computer
everything's done with binary but it
turns out binary is a bit unwieldy so
in addition to the binary number system
and of course our own
decimal number system computers often
use a hexadecimal number system in fact
i would say that
you're more likely to see hexadecimal
when working with computers than binary
just because
binary is just really difficult to work
with
so in this video we're going to take a
look at how the hexadecimal number
system works
hexadecimal is base 16. we've previously
seen that
binary is base 2 and therefore we only
have 2 digits 0 and 1
and of course decimal is base 10 and so
we have the
10 digits 0 through 9 and so
hex the decimal is going to have 16
digits
but of course we don't have 16 digits so
what we're going to do is we're going to
borrow
the letters a b c d e
and f and when you add that to 0 to 9
you end up with 16 digits
why do we use hexadecimal well consider
this sequence of binary
digits here this particular sequence of
bits is actually an ad
instruction for the mips cpu
and treating it as binary is somewhat of
a problem
there's a number of issues with looking
at this as binary one it's really long
and as a consequence it's pretty
unwieldy i personally find it a little
intimidating looking at these long
sequences of zeros and ones but more
important
it's error prone working with all these
zeros and ones it's really easy to
accidentally mix one of the zeros and
the ones
or to just completely skip one of them
and realize when you're done that
gee i was supposed to have 32 bits and i
only ended up with 29 i wonder which one
i skipped
so we want something that's a little bit
more compact
now we can use the decimal number system
so if one were to work out the
equivalent
it turns out this is equivalent of 21
880 in base 10 and that is quite a bit
more compact
but moving from binary to decimal is
kind of a pain
we've seen how to do it before i'm here
we're doing it with just four bits but
you can imagine doing with the 32 bits
on the previous page is going to be a
big mess
and i haven't shown you how to move in
the opposite direction
from decimal to binary because it turns
out it's a real pain
so i personally try and avoid it
whenever possible
here's the problem decimal is base 10
and 10 really doesn't have anything to
do with two
there's a number of different number
systems that work quite a bit
better with binary than the decimal
number system does
one of them is octal and the other one
is hexadecimal
and these work much better because
octal's base 8
and 2 to the third power is 8 and
hexadecimal
is base 16 and
2 to the fourth power is 16 and so
there's a natural
relationship between base 8 and 2
and base 16 of 2 that just isn't there
for base 10 and 2.
and it turns out that because 16 is 2 to
the fourth power
every 4 bits corresponds to hexadecimal
digit
so there's a natural breaking point
where you can look at every
four bits and say okay that's a
hexadecimal digit that's hexadecimal
digit that's hexadecimal
you can't do that at all with decimal
and since we're
not really usually working with four
bits at a time we're actually working at
eight with eight bits at a time it turns
out that
every byte corresponds to a pair of
hexadecimal digits so a lot of times
when you're working with hexadecimal
you'll see
lots of pairs of hexadecimal digits
we'll see examples of this in a minute
okay so here's a 24-bit color
from one of our previous lectures this
particular color is cardinal red this is
the official color that stanford uses
for cardinal red
and you can see we've got our binary
numbers up top
we've got our decimal equivalence
underneath it although
converting from the binary to the
decimal numbers is again a bit of a pain
and so what i'm going to show you is how
to convert from the binary to
the hexadecimal and this is going to
turn out to be easier
all right so we can immediately break
down each of these
numbers into sets of four each of these
sets of four here is going to
correspond to a hexadecimal digit
and then to start off with you can just
use a table and so here's a table of
all the possible combinations of four
bits and their hexadecimal equivalents
but as you continue to get better at it
you'll be able to do conversions between
the two pretty easily
you can do conversions of four bits to
decimal without
too much trouble although i do tend to
stall out if i'm in the middle of
lecture
and i need to do a conversion you'll see
me puzzle over the problem for about a
second or two and just stall on lecture
but if i need to do more than four bit
conversion to
decimal i'm just gonna have to whip out
a piece of paper i'm not gonna do an
eight bit
conversion uh in my head while
everybody's staring at me in lecture
that's just
i'm sure there are other people that are
much better at it but i just can't do it
all right so we're going to take our
little table here or we can just go with
our
the right hand digit is our ones the
next one is our twos next ones are fours
and the last ones are eight
so if we follow the ones two four eight
you can see that this number here one
zero
zero zero this is actually an eight or i
can look it up on my table here on the
right
okay so 1 0 0 0 base 2
is 8 base 16.
and now let's do a full byte so this is
a byte from our color 1 0 0 0
1 1 0 0 and immediately this is where
it comes in handy compared to decimal if
i were going to do the decimal
conversions i have to go oh that's the
ones that's the twos that's the fours
that's the eights that's the sixteens
that's the 32s that's a 64. so that's
128.
and if the number gets much bigger you
know 256
512 1024 you're trying to remember which
place goes with what gets really messy
but with hexadecimal i don't do that i
just split this thing in half i say
i just want sets of four bits so i say
i've got two sets of four bits
one set on the left one set on the right
the set on the left we already did but
you can do it really easy in your head
one two four eight remember each of the
places is ones
the twos the fours and the eights and so
we can see i mean we have eight on the
left
on the right we've got one two four
eight and that's 12
in decimal and again that seems pretty
easy you're like why don't we just use
decimal the problem is
that only the the decimal conversion
only works
quickly if we have small numbers of bits
the hexadecimal conversion
always works quickly because we never
have more than four bits because we can
always break the binary number into sets
of four bits
all right so we can look this up in our
table or we can do in our head and we
can see that this corresponds to a
c and so we can see that this particular
bit sequence we've converted the first
four bits to eight
and the second four bits to c and so
combined together
we can see that this whole sequence is
8c let's do
another one and so this is another one
of the components of our
cardinal red color and i take the bits
and i immediately break them into sets
of four and i can see i have two sets of
four the seven on the left is super
super easy
because that's clearly a one and a set
on the right we have our ones our twos
and our fours and so i can see that's a
five
and so i can see that this converts to
one five
and in fact here's the full color
sequence here
the amount of red is 8c the amount of
green is 1 5 and the amount of blue is 1
5. and this is actually how it's
commonly going to be represented
and so what we see here is the official
color guide from stanford
and you can see they've got a bunch of
different possible representations of
this including
remember we've got the rgb that's our
additive color red green blue
and then we have our subtractive color
for printing that's our cmyk
cyan magenta yellow and key or black
and you can see down at the bottom they
have the hex and they have the hex
listing which is what
what we originally converted this to
they have that hex listing there because
that's what the world wide web uses
and then this is the color selector in
photoshop
photoshop has a web color setting and
you can see that the web color setting
again
uses these hexadecimal digits
so the point is if you're going to be
doing art particularly art for the web
you should be familiar with hexadecimal
numbers these hexadecimal numbers are
going to show up in
lots of other places as well when we're
looking at addresses on the network
we'll see that hexadecimal digits show
up on network physical addresses
these are the addresses associated with
your device that you
have to tell stanford when you go ahead
and register your computer
with stanford so it will let you on the
network hexadecimal numbers
are commonly used when identifying
individual bits
in computer memory and
another place you may see hexadecimal
numbers is
when you see error messages when the
computer crashes you will often see
hexadecimal not
super helpful but you know you'll
recognize you're like oh that's great my
computer crashed on me oh and hey look i
have special number i learned that in my
computer science class
you could tell you're looking at
hexadecimal when you're looking at
something that kind of looks like a
number
but in addition to the digits 0 through
9 you have a b
c d e and f mixed in so you can see on
the bottom right there
i have what looks kind of like a bunch
of numbers but i also have those fs and
a's in there and so
once you get trained for this you
immediately look at that say oh that
must be hexadecimal
in addition though it turns out that
there's a convention that sometimes used
not always but
when we're working with computers often
if a number is preceded by a single
zero that indicates that we're actually
looking at a
octal number and octal
octal is used because octal is base
eight and eight is a power of 2
and so i think it was used quite a bit
for a while but
we've mostly moved text a decimal but if
you see something with a 0 followed by
a bunch of digits that's octal number
and if you see something started with a
0x
as we see in our computer memory here
that's representing
a hexadecimal number so if you look at
this little
sequence here if we just see a 12 by
itself that's probably base 10.
if we see 0 1 2 that's a 1
2 and base eight and we see a zero x one
two
that's a one two in base 16. all right
that's it for our little introduction
hexadecimal but you will be seeing
hexadecimals throughout the quarter
you